in unseren ins eis zeigen wir euch jetzt
die tattoos der promis und die
außergewöhnlichen stellen an denen sie
diese manchmal haben gerade erst haben
jimi blue ochsenknecht und seine
freundin jedes ihre beziehung öffentlich
gemacht und schon tätowieren sie sich
gegenseitig die beiden haben sich nicht
nur unter die nadel getraut sondern auch
dahinter
während jedes jimmy ein smiley
tätowierte hat jimmy sich mit einem
kleineren herz für ein etwas
romantisches motiv entschieden
ich muss man sieben baby blue und jedes
sind allerdings nicht die einzigen
promis die besondere tattoos bevorzugen
model betty tauber hat sich beim stechen
ihrer tattoos zwar für einen profi
entschieden umso außergewöhnlicher sind
jedoch die stellen an denen sie diese
hart und hat sie mehr zu ihren tattoos
erzählt radio playlist habe ich ja
einige kleine tattoos was jetzt nicht
auslösen wie viel arbeit die stellen wo
ich manche tattoo habe sind schon
außergewöhnlich zum beispiel habe ich an
meine lippe dann steht grave und ich
habe seit zwei tagen eine kleine burg in
meiner hand und da bin ich so stolz
drauf und ich werde dann immer gesagt
tut das nicht mega mega mega alle haben
mich gewarnt sogar meine titel wäre drin
hat gesagt bist du dir sicher dass es
mit die schmerzhafteste stelle die es
zum titel ihren gibt und ich dachte
sogar bin mir sicher
und er hat sie angefangen und sehr
unangenehm sehr unangenehm aber es war
auch völlig auszuhalten
dazu muss ich sagen dass ich diese art
von schmerz eigentlich freuen
ich finde das irgendwie beruhigend wenn
wir das war sehr schmerzhaft du musst
dir das vorstellen als wenn dem es
annehmen würde und tatsächlich einfach
nur meine freunde
also ich glaube jedem ist das mädchen
finden anders aber ich habe über den und
in den stollen gehören auch dominik
erlitten hat sich vor ein paar tagen
wieder unter die nadel gelegt dieses mal
gibt es ein ganz besonderes motiv der
youtuber ist bekannt für seine vielen
tattoos und macht mit seinem letzten nun
eine liebeserklärung der besonderen art
an seine beiden töchter mirós und keiler
sein handrücken zeigt nun ein
märchenschloss in kombination mit den
sternzeichen seiner prinzessinnen die
liebe zu ihren kindern trägt auch model
amber rose unter der haut und dafür hat
sie eine ganz besondere stelle gewählt
die ex von kanye west hat sich anfang
des jahres die namen ihrer söhne auf die
stirn tätowieren lassen
wenn das ihren söhnen pesch und / nicht
beweist wie sehr sie mama am herzen
liegen aber nicht nur die liebe zur
familie wird bei den promis durch
tattoos zum ausdruck gebracht auch
freundschafts tattoos liegen hoch und
trennt die models kaya gerber und
caravelle wien haben sich stadt dem
englischen soulmate mit was so viel wie
seelenverwandt bedeutet das wort
soulmate nur mit tätowierten lassen
damit sind sie per übersetzung nun ganz
offiziell sohlen verwandt doof nur dass
das tattoo gar nicht auf der fußsohle
ist
[Musik]